[Music]
even born yourself his sports catamaran
around the globe a journey of 55,000
kilometers with no cabin or GPS we met
up with him in Paris to find out what
inspired his voyage I know it's a stupid
idea but it's my patient since I'm 13
years old and also when I was young I
did this trip with my parents but we
were for sure bigger boat and I really
wanted for two years after to see what
happened during my when I was young with
my life and to understand where I come
from a professional sailor Eva Bono has
won many prizes and set world records in
2010 he crossed the Mediterranean in
less than 53 hours then he decided to
embark on his dream to sail around the
world he set out from France on October
5th 2013 after crossing the Atlantic and
the Caribbean he passed through the
Panama Canal during the voyage he
crossed three oceans and 13 season all
my idea was to learn in fact was to
learn every day to discover how to
practice this catamaran alone I
practiced during 30 years only two
people on board so I really discover
what's happening he knew from the start
that the trip would be extremely
dangerous sailing alone in a sports
catamaran but when all has always loved
challenges even if they don't go as
planned I had a very bad time I almost
died when I capsized because my boat
pushed very fast and me I was in the
water and I start to to have the water
inside and it was very dangerous
[Music]
Bono's experience has now featured on
the international ocean filmed her the
two-hour program aims to show the oceans
and all their diversity and encourage
people to take action towards protecting
them it includes six films at all among
them dolphin man a documentary about the
legendary French free diver Jacques
Mayol who died in 2001
in 1976 mayor descended to a depth of a
hundred metres without an oxygen tank in
the big wave project some of the world's
best surfers ride huge waves off the
coast of Portugal near Nazare Vermes he
showcases the diversity of marine life
and the spectacular coral reef of the
karrimba archipelago in northern
Mozambique
in the ocean rider the viewer almost
feels like they're sitting in the
catamaran themselves during the voyage
storms cold and severe heat made it
difficult for Yvonne boney on to sleep
eventually he began suffering from
hallucinations I just decided to buy
some bread and I just go in the water
and when I was in the water I said okay
no it's not the bakery yeah I have to go
back on the boat
yeah because I was so tired after four
days without sleep disaster struck his
catamaran founded on the rock coast of
Sri Lanka
was nighttime I didn't know where I was
I couldn't imagine and see the waves I
just see the boat cracks
police there assumed he was a drug
dealer and he was briefly held in jail
monie all had the boat repaired and set
off again on June the 3rd 2015 he
finally ended his voyage off the town of
Wooster um in northern France he had
spent 220 days on the open water
it's very simple I ran but everything is
possible when you want it that's it as
simple but also very risky rule to live
by
but his reward was accomplishing
something unique and around-the-world
voyage in a catamaran